so we think of ourselves as dynamic
autonomous creatures that have agency
and free will right we move about the
world and things don't influence us
because we have free will we have the
capacity to decide at every moment who
we are and where we're going right that
is what we do except when you look
deeper you actually find that mind okay
that consciousness is in fact not
necessarily autonomous from the world in
which it dwells in other words
consciousness is a co-production
consciousness is a collaboration between
subject and object
professor David Lentz and writes about
this in his book so consider what that
means it basically means there's not
just one type of consciousness right
there is this notion that it's person x
place x time that reveals a guard in the
forking paths of possible consciousness
of possible entities and that your
consciousness is mediated again if you
think about what I'm saying
consciousness is mediated by the spaces
that we dwell in other words the designs
that we create design us in return right
onto logical design so what does that
mean it means that the people you hang
with determined you are it means that
the language you speak sculpt your
perception of the world it means that
the culture in which you live shapes
your worldview it means that the people
that you meet meet you in return and
thus affect you
we are mediated beings the clothing that
we wear uniforms can structure our
beliefs about the world I mean even
typography can change how you think and
how you perceive it this notion that the
wallpaper of the mind can influence
reality so much can influence
consciousness can influence perception
to the degree that who and what we are
is determined by where we are and where
we dwell the wallpaper matters right
what is within is without what is
without is within we're like the dragon
eating its own tail we're the Earl
Burroughs okay your ester is hands the
hand is drawing the hand that's drawing
the original hand that's us and again
what does it take away of this idea that
we can create our own reality that our
creative and linguistic choices govern
our fate I design therefore I become the
Vertigo of freedom
you